well this is a very interesting and deep
and
topical question
if i put my hand in front of the beam a
large hadron collider
what would happen to my hand don't know
don't know don't know not a good idea i
wouldn't recommend it and in fact of
course you can't the the beam is 100
meters
underground i really don't know i mean
you've got these things coming together
and you would have thought it'd be
extremely dangerous
somebody would yank you out of there
before you could do that
i oh gosh
i don't think you'd feel very much
that's a good question i don't know is
the answer probably be very bad for you
and they'd be very cross with you as
well i can say
i don't know the total amount of energy
that'll be distributed i don't know the
energy density the beam
is sending protons in one direction and
of course there's a counter beam going
in the other direction
these protons are going have an energy
of order
when it's reached its maximum of order
of seven
tera electron volts that's about the
energy of a mosquito so it's not a lot
right it's of one proton of it
but the difference is this energy is
like concentrated into a volume a
million million times smaller than the
mosquito so it's like a really sharp
pinprick
but it's still only one proton
unfortunately there are uh something
like 3000 bunches
uh going around the beam around the
accelerator each bunch has 100 billion
protons but by the scale of energies
that we we notice it wouldn't it
wouldn't be that noticeable be
interesting i
would i would i put my hand in the beam
i'm not sure about that because the
other thing is i've worked at
synchrotrons and the real problem with
with if you're getting off synchrotron
radiation because you've got particles
traveling very close to the the speed of
light if they're accelerated then you're
getting off synchrotron radiation and
synchrotron radiation is very nasty when
they collide them together there are
something like 600 million collisions
per second
so there's a lot of collisions go on
the total energy stored in the beam
whereas the energy in an individual
proton may not be very high the total
energy stored in that beam is about
300
megajoules
that's like the energy of an aircraft
carrier moving at 11 knots
so now
that beam's going to come around it's
suddenly going to hit your your hand or
your body however whatever you've put in
and it's got to deposit that energy
so it's like being hit by a massive
object and i don't think you'll uh
survive very much because it's just
hitting such a small space won't it just
drill the ultimate hole through your
hand why would it start affecting other
parts of your body
and it's that's where i that's why i was
hesitating
at the beginning because i don't really
know what will happen when they collide
they they they
the beam has ranges from a width of
about a millimeter
down to a width of about i think
um
like a fifth of a hair
hairs width when they actually collide
the beam so they're really narrow when
they collide them when they're not being
collided they're about a millimeter so
they're going to come in and crash in
here so i have thought maybe they'll
just shoot through but but it seems to
me that what's got to happen is this
energy has all got to be dumped
because it's now hitting a lot of matter
normally it doesn't hit anything that
it's a real it's a almost a total vacuum
in the in those things in the in the
accelerator ring but now
there's this big high density region and
so all these particles it seems to me
will just hitting there and just start
bombing out so that's why
i thought it might be a bit more
dramatic than a little pinprick going
straight through you
there's a vacuum there so that might
have some unpleasant consequences on on
my hand pressure pressure change
but i don't think it would have a huge
effect
if there was a galaxy made completely
out of anti-particles
would it behave the same way as ours so
the main thing that goes on in galaxies
is is gravitational right and gravity
doesn't care whether you're a particle
or an antiparticle gravity cares about
the fact you've got a mass
and so as far as gravity is concerned as
far as forming this
anti-galaxy if you like i think
um
that dynamics would be the same with
regard to the actual interactions uh
assuming that uh
the anti-hydrogen can form for example
so an anti-electron and an antiproton
then i suppose the same basic processes
can take place
they will emit light when they interact
with one another because the light is
just an emission of energy
and as long as that's still taking place
and energy is being lost then you'll
still have light the reason we know the
universe doesn't have such galaxies in
it is that actually even the empty space
between galaxies isn't completely empty
and so this galaxy would actually start
interacting with its neighbors and of
course when the mata comes into contact
with the antimatter it would annihilate
to be a big burst of gamma rays and the
fact that we don't see a very large
gamma-ray background in the entire
universe tells us that the universe
isn't actually full of antimatter
galaxies as well as mata galaxies
at the point when the universe came into
existence so did all the forces and
physical constants which affect the
universe today
however if the universe was to come into
existence again like another big bang
would we have all the same forces and
the same physical constants oh okay so
this is the sort of multiverse idea and
the fact that we have we could have a
wide range of different universes with
different physical constants oh that's a
good question um
that's a difficult question to answer
because of course you can't do the
experiment you know what physicists like
to do is do an experiment and we're not
allowed to make universes or at least we
haven't figured out how to do it yet uh
the idea now is that your little bubble
universes can can pop up everywhere and
it's thought that right in the early
stages the fundamental constants can be
different
and the question then arises what would
it be like living in a universe where
the fundamental constants were different
where the mass
the electron was different or its charge
or planck's constant were different and
so on and this is a fascinating question
um so it's not clear there's even there
are theories that actually say that the
universe didn't come into being as a
single universe as actually lots and
lots of universes were created thing
called the multiverse and in some of
them the kind of the laws of physics
work and some of them they don't and so
the ones where the laws of physics work
kind of thrive and take over um and so
it could be that there may be other
universes out there that have very
different laws of physics different
values for physical constants and so on
so but but it's a sort of again it's
sort of on the realms of philosophy
rather than physics because it's not
something you can really do an
experiment to test
we get the same forces as a physical now
that's
that's really beyond anybody's
imagination i think that the current
understanding is in terms of a
multiverse situation at least that um
there could be other universes with
radically different physical consonants
i mean dirac said that god thought that
god created the universe with beautiful
mathematics and you're asking the
question if he does it again or she does
it again is it going to be the same
mathematics or is he going to twist it
around in some way
so i really don't know the answer that
question i don't know that you could
ever begin to answer that question what
we can't explain even with within the
context of string theory at the moment
is the relative magnitude of those
forces we still don't know why gravity
is so weak compared say to
electromagnetism
we can measure it and we can understand
it in terms of the the constants but we
can't predict those constants
and the electric charge why it's got the
value it has the masses of the particles
why they have the values they have so
until we can do that and and and and
definitively say this comes from
um this is a unique solution that can
have no other values
then you can't say that if if in a
parallel universe it suddenly popped up
you know universe popped up in a um that
you would have all the same couplings
but it turns out that that we have to be
very careful about how many of these
constants that we could imagine turning
around because there are certain
scenarios that if the constants were
very much different from what they are
we wouldn't be around to
to to to observe it i mean so certain
values of the constants are just not con
conducive to life or and certainly not
to intelligent life so for example
gravity has to be extremely extremely
weak
what would happen to the earth if one of
the closer stars like alpha centauri is
the example we were given went supernova
would the earth be protected by its
magnetic field alpha centauri won't go
supernova
um if a close star went supernova then
there would be radiation coming at all
wavelengths but it turns out our
atmosphere does a very good job of
deflecting that radiation i mean
radiation comes from the sun all the
time but we're not affected by rape by
x-rays for instance well this is a
common doomsday scenario right supernova
explosions are some of the biggest
most catastrophic events that we know of
in the universe so it's very reasonable
to say what would happen if one happened
nearby we know that the sun will not go
supernova it's not the right type of
star it's not massive enough to go
supernova
but maybe there are some stars in our
neighborhood that might
we actually know that of the type of
stars that are likely to end their lives
in a supernovae there aren't that many
that are that nearby
so for something called a type 2
supernova which is when a star just gets
really massive and blows itself up one
of the nearest candidates for that is
actually the star beetlejuice
it's a famous word and it's also a
famous star it's actually the the
shoulder of orion one of the the
well-known constellations it's very red
and we know that it's actually
probably nearing the end of its life
maybe not on the time scale of humans
watching it
but it could be thousands it could be
just millions of years away
still the main damage we wouldn't get
very much optical damage other than
looking at it so
if a star supernova it'll get very
bright and it could affect our eyes just
as when you look at the sun it will
affect our eyes but even then betelgeuse
which is about 400 light years away it's
still too far away luckily to probably
cause us most damn enough damage if it
went it would be quite spectacular we
would probably see it with the naked eye
in the daytime that would be the visible
light output we'd have to worry about
something like uh gamma ray radiation
but even then it's it's probably too far
away thankfully to do much damage
do you have a favorite symbol and why
oh my favorite symbol
i don't know if we've done the favorite
one yet but my favorite symbol at the
moment is probably lambda the
cosmological constant
because it's this enigmatic
quantity
which could actually be driving the
acceleration of the universe today
and no one knows why it's got the value
it has
we should do it we should do a video on
it oh the fine structure constant alpha
one over 137.0599
it's my favorite look at our 60 symbols
video on it
on alpha
i quite like the symbol for infinity
because it's a cool concept it's a
really hard thing to get your head
around but also it's just a nice symbol
and it kind of kind of packages packages
up what it means you know you've got
this infinite loop that just keeps going
round and round and round so it kind of
does what it says on the tin i guess my
favorite symbol is a slightly unusual
one
which is a symbol called epsilon greek
letter looks like a seagull
and it's used by astronomers to measure
the mass to light ratio of things how
much master is and how much light there
is
and you've discussed it on 60 symbols
and we made a video and it's not one of
the most popular ones i'm sad to relate
yes i think my favorite symbol is the
infinity symbol i really like the
concept of infinity even though i think
about it a lot it just blows my mind
every time and i just like the little
infinity you can just kind of go on
forever
so i guess aesthetically or in terms of
the background of the symbol that's what
the symbol actually means i guess those
are two separate chromosomes
aesthetically
either psy
pitchfork one or big sigma which is sort
of this sort of looks to me almost like
a strange sort of pac-man type thing
in terms of what the symbol means and
relates to to my work i guess it's got
to be planck's constant um largely
because planck's consonant is
fundamentally embedded in quantum
mechanics the the study of small things
well i've thought about this and i will
go for a ket no no for a bra because
dirac invented this wonderful notation
there's something like that which he
called a bra and something like that
which he called a ket and the two
together made a bracket a bracket
and he was really proud of it because
this word bra is in the english
dictionary it is an actual word in
english and he invented it
and he's proud of it he was proud of it
because he was in the dictionary not
realizing that it had other connotations